I think of what reform has to accomplish
as three things when is it has to cover
everybody both for moral reasons as well
as economic reasons it's untenable to be
in a society where any change in your
circumstance like for example a
recession can mean you're out of the
health care system second is it has to
modernize the health care system so that
we really get money for what we put into
it we really get value for what we put
into it the misconception that you
referenced is that the idea the goal is
to save money the goal is not to save
money the goal is to do things where
they're appropriate and not do them
where they're not appropriate which is a
way of looking at it that's much more
consistent with where people are the
values that we have and then the third
thing that we need in reform is we need
a public health system that actually
works to keep us healthy to keep us safe
that reinforces our medical care system
from things like h1n1 flu avian flu to
food and water safety to obesity and
smoking cessation
what people need to understand about
healthcare reform is that we can improve
the quality of care and lower spending
at the same time think about those
patients with chronic disease who are
not getting treated appropriately treat
them more appropriately they don't go
into the hospital they spend less and
their quality of life their length of
life is increased that's what we can do
if we really do it right so yes we need
to save money but we will save money as
a byproduct of having a system that
works better we're not going to save
money by taking a meat axe and just
clawing off some part of health care
spending that's what a lot of the
alternative is if we don't do this
what's going to happen probably a lot of
employers will just say hey you know
what we're just going to stick you in a
health plan with very high cost share
and you go out and deal with it
everything we know is that people will
stop taking their medications they'll
save money and their health will
deteriorate we have to find a way and we
believe there are ways where we can save
money and we can improve health and
people know this people know that the
health care system costs more than it
should and a part of that is because the
thing just doesn't work right and you
wind up having people in very expensive
circumstances after the fact when you
could have prevented it so I don't think
that convincing people of that
presumption is that hard I think what we
have to do is one make sure we do that
make sure we put the steps in place to
do that and second is we need to make
sure we don't demagogue it so we just
say to people oh what the president
wants is to ration your care or what
senator Kennedy wants is to make sure
you don't get so we need to get away
from that because people without it's
complicated enough no one's going to
understand all the details and if people
hear those things and they get scared
then they'll be tempted to back off and
that would be just the worst of all
situations
you